hello and bilder tansy and today is
April 27 2012 we're speaking with Jamie
genuine she's an architect designer and
artist the founder of my studio and
co-founder of Halloran yoon architecture
and on my team is yoon is associate
professor and director of the
undergraduate program in architecture
welcome Eugen Yoon thank you
so the MIT community probably best knows
your work with from the fast festival
last year as part of the 150 celebration
when you it's fair to say dressed the
MIT campus with art can you describe how
that came about and how you felt about
how it went well I think the fast
festival was an amazing opportunity to
bring together different disciplines
around the arts at MIT the notion of
having a festival for art science and
technology I thought was fantastic and
Todd Mac over brought me on board to
curate a series of installations by
students and faculty all around campus
and the idea was to curate it in such a
way that over the course of a semester
these installations would like pop up in
unexpected spaces first in kind of
interior niches and circulatory areas to
create a kind of sense of well what is
that and transform the space for an
instance and then culminate in a series
of more I would say strategically place
installations that highlighted the river
axis of MIT
so the initial interior projects from
the winter months happened along the
infinite corridor axis and then the
spring summer installations happened
along the memo Memorial Drive right
along the river and it was a way to kind
of gesture the Boston and Cambridge like
this is also our front door even though
the kind of internal community really
uses
infinite corridor kind of circulation
way of expanding out yeah it was a way
of sort of turning MIT inside out you
know for a brief brief moment to the
public and I think that this wasn't just
faculty work this was student workers
yes absolutely it was probably 50%
student work maybe more than 50% student
work and 50% faculty work and we really
did try to encourage collaborations
between theater students and
architecture students and Media Lab
students for those projects can you give
me an example of one of those student
door interactive brochure there was a
project right off the infinite corridor
that was done by a PhD computation
student to PhD computation students who
collaborated with some of the Media Lab
electronics engineers and they created a
kind of interactive wall that was all
magnetized and so like the magnet the
poles on the magnets created like
different kinetic movement on the
installation yeah so as I walked by it
would move it was it wasn't responding
to necessarily your movement but you
were moving the installation and it was
triggering different lights as you did
that so here's a question I often hear
artists talk about this will make me
think what's happening here this will
make me think afresh about my
environment can you say more about that
like why is that a good thing
okay so you know one of the student
installations it was called discourse
for their course for students and what
they did was in one of the four-story
stairwells they hung a giant I can only
describe it as a chandelier but it was
basically a modular piece that was made
out of different units that could
basically aggregate in a way that
tapered in and then back out again in
that four-story stairwell and what's
interesting is like we're above or next
to or we meaning architectures next to
make
Chemical Engineering and then there's
another department the floor below etc
but when this installation happened
people like I think went out of their
way to actually circulate on this
stairwell as opposed to going I know I
did because it was such a beautiful
installation and you would see people
you know kind of obliquely one floor
below and it did kind of foster because
it was so unfamiliar by taking by
basically D familiarizing ones
environmental context it creates
discussion and questioning and asking oh
who is one floor below us you know in
mechanical engineering that's great so
partly I think on the basis of the
success of fast it was tremendously
enjoyed by the community and survey said
that this is we should do more of this
at MIT the university just announced a
new program cast or the Center for art
science and technology
I mean what's art doing in the mix here
at MIT anyway what aren't artists as far
apart as engineer from engineers as you
can get I mean I think if you look at
the MIT community the artists here their
work is inseparable from science and
technology and I do think there are
certain artists that might not intersect
with science and technology but in the
sense of like the quintessential
Leonardo da Vinci's of the world art
science and technology were always
intertwined you know an architect
inventor you know astronomer you know
and I think that notion still exists
today and many people and I'm always
amazed to find you know engineers who
are amazingly creative or mathematicians
who are amazingly creative and then
artists or architects who are incredibly
rigorous and about their their design
research so I don't think art science
and technology to me they seem much more
seamless than I think maybe the way our
educational kind of context not MIT is
educational context but you know we grow
up and think
oh you either go to a humanity school or
you go to a School of Science and
Technology you're either an artsy
literary type of person or a science
math person but you know especially when
you're at MIT you find so many amazing
students in math and science are
brilliant musicians or artists or
designers you know so I think this place
makes you more aware of the seamlessness
between art science and technology and
if he talked to faculty I'm always
amazed that the the lines are so Criss
crossing across the disciplines that
it's it's very hard to you know you meet
someone and they're like oh I do
structural origami and then you're like
huh well that has so much to do with
structures and architecture and design
but they're looking at it from math or a
biologist who's looking at how certain
components come to we would think of
them as components but he's of course
thinking of them as cellular aggregation
you know and how how similar we are
thinking about building module
aggregation there's so much to learn
from each other but if we're kind of
separated into these silos that never
happened so what was amazing about fast
was like its ability to foreground art
Science and Technology I think MIT is a
place where no one questions the science
and technology but this is a place with
amazing creative arts and humanities and
the opportunity to really bring that to
the forefront for the 150th celebration
was I think a great great opportunity
for those of us in those fields but also
I think MIT became very or more aware of
the kind of potential in the arts as it
relates to the Institute in general
showing the community to excel fourth
side of itself I wasn't aware of yes
absolutely I mean the number of people
the fast festival drew from the general
Cambridge Boston community I think it
was a way of making the campus more
accessible to a general public there was
in every installation there was research
and technology involved from digital
fabrication to rethinking modular
aggregation to new materials through
energy production with the Solar rockers
by Sheila Kennedy I think people became
aware that oh there is science and
technology but it can be beautiful and
change our environment and be
pleasurable and be playful as well it's
great is that part of I'm there's a
quote we found that or what's been
called there's a kind of chain reaction
that happens between the arts science
and technology at MIT is is the kind of
thing here yeah absolutely I mean I
think the school like the Media Lab is
probably one of the let's say buildings
or envelopes that has the most variables
but there's artists there because the
art culture technology program is based
there there are designers and architects
in terms of students and faculty in the
Media Lab but there's also scientists
physicists engineers etc and I think you
can sense in the kind of amazing
production that place generates a just a
creative energy you know and I think
that creative energy comes from the
synergy of multiple disciplines I think
you need to bump up against people from
other disciplines in order to request
not only how you think about your own
discipline but oh in fact art aren't we
much more connected than we think in our
and our desire to
change the world you know but through
different different avenues there's I
was looking at one of your talks and you
talked about art science and
technologies being something when you
put them together you get a whole that's
great it's more than just plus signs
between them yeah absolutely yeah can
you say a little more of I mean you have
to say yeah I mean I think that when
there is synergy between three things
you get much more than the sum of its
parts I think that the much more is you
get something unexpected you know like I
think typically you can guess you know
what this kind of research might lead to
what this kind of research might lead to
but you know recently one of our alums
Skylar Tibbits who's one of the TED
Fellows this year is collaborating with
the biologist and they're working on
basically the biologist is working on an
area we're researching how cells know
what - what can combine and what could
not combine sorry that's my very low low
biology speak of that isn't that idea
and Skylar is also looking at it by just
using mechanical energy so like shaking
a tube of different modules they
aggregate in precise ways because the
modules are designed so they only go
together one way and not another way and
that he learned through biology through
this collaboration and I think you put
two people in two different disciplines
together and you ask them maybe you
should have coffee or a discussion and
collaborate you can't force
collaboration but I think you never know
what's gonna come out of that I know
crash crash of ideas that's great and
there's a lot of that going on in my -
yeah courage so I want to back up for a
minute we'll come back to MIT sure sure
I want to back up for a minute and talk
about what brought you to this point
I'll let go all the way back without
telling your whole life story I can
supply that from my research that you
were born in Seoul yes I was born in
Seoul Korea
but I grew up mostly in the United
States I studied I had a very
traditional architectural education I
have a Bachelors of architecture from
Cornell and then a master's of
architecture and urban design from
Harvard but when I graduated I did a
Fulbright in Korea and I wanted to work
on very big scale urban projects because
in Korea at the time cities for $300,000
we hundred sorry cities for 300,000
people were being built overnight and I
thought well we need designers to think
about that after a year of working at an
urban Research Institute I thought that
is an important cause but that's not
what I love I love cities but I want to
do it hands-on not through policy and
not through sketches that will take you
no time to turn into a master plan for
traffic engineers to resolve etc I
wanted a more immediate way of changing
the urban environment and I thought you
could change urban environment through
small scale interventions so I started
my own kind of practice doing
installation work in public space I one
of the maybe most known projects as a
project called white noise white light
for the Athens 2004 Olympics that
doesn't explain how I got to MIT so I
came to MIT in 2001 and I came out of a
invitation to apply for a junior faculty
position in architecture and what's
amazing is I think MIT changed my life
not only that it gave me a job but it
changed the course of the way I thought
about architecture and the city yeah how
did you been here 10 years ago I'd been
here 10 so when I came in 2001 as I
mentioned I had a very traditional
architectural and urban design education
one that was devoid of any technology in
terms of the way I was trained was not
exposed to so many things about design
and technology in terms of
computer-aided design or manufacturing
etc so when I came here in 2001 because
MIT has that word technology in it I was
very nervous and so my first semester of
teaching I also signed up to be a
student so I took a course at the Media
Lab called how to make almost anything
which is taught by Neil Gershenfeld
because I thought I am so techno you
know phobic I should take a course that
you know makes me less fearful of
technology so during that first semester
I was teaching a studio and then
simultaneously I was a student and MIT
is this great benefit where they pay
your tuition if you take a course but
you have to get a B or above to get
reimbursed for that course so it was
like the only course I actually ever
cared about my grade because I was
worried that I wouldn't get it
reimbursed but I got an 8 and I learned
a lot through that class because it was
a crash course in computer-aided design
manufacturing basic electronics
microcontrollers prototyping and the
final project of that class from for my
final assignment I created something
called the defensible dress and later
iterations of that dress you know were
exhibited at the LA mocha and the
National Museum in Tokyo but the idea
behind the dress was I want to defend my
personal space from people that crowded
in urban contexts and so when anyone
entered a space zone that I could preset
of you know 24 inches was my comfort
sound and then culturally it's different
you know if you're in Spain versus Tokyo
so the idea was you could program your
distance your personal space distance if
anyone violated that this dress like
lifted like a porcupine with these
spikes
kept people away did you ever wear it I
did wear it in public and I had students
wear it in public and it was shown on a
mannequin and the museum's but what was
that experience like just briefly
whatever I think people I think people
were like what's that hey they are kind
of surprised by it but at the same time
I think it resonated with everybody at
the same time it's a crazy project but
everyone has had in public space a
feeling of kind of personal space
encroachment and that was the project
that you could deal with kind of big
scale issues through a small personal
scale intervention and that's what led
to the white noise white light project
for the Athens Olympics that's what has
led to a lot of my work that deals with
interactive design and alternative
energy and transforming a public space
so we're going to crest one more step
and then we'll come back how a likety
changed you so in teaching how do
students respond to this I'm thinking of
and I may have a wrong stereotype yeah
of the engineer where everything has to
be quantified and logical and explained
this idea of the defensible dress a big
abstract idea in a concrete object and
the effective it is hard to put into
words arts often beyond words how do you
translate that to students and how do
they how do they respond to get
resistance um you know in I feel like at
MIT you don't get resistance I mean I
think the first resistance would be a
person that would ask well why would you
want to do that but I think MIT or I've
never found anyone that asked me why
would you want to do that it's ah that's
really strange but that's kind of
interesting so how are you going to do
that and I think that's I mean that's
the nature of Neal's course how to make
almost anything not what should me wait
what should we make you know why should
we make it so I think that is you know
in a way Neal's course coupled with the
kind of just general fearlessness about
my tea you know like there is an
attitude of you know not why but why not
and a lot of support you know so I could
take a class as a faculty member I could
learn about things that I was sort of
afraid to love to admit that I didn't
know much about you know when I started
here and it did change the trajectory of
my work you know and I it could only
have happened here if I had taken a
teaching position and any other school
my work would not be the work it is
today you've lost your technophobia
technophile day well you know I would
say I am still wary of technology but I
think that wariness is a super-healthy
aspect of the work too but I I am
fearless because I now know people who
are fearless you know once we were doing
a project it was a sound installation
east capaci sensing and it produced
sounds so I was like well we should you
know get a small mp3 player and you know
and the engineer I was working with us
like why would we buy an mp3 player I'm
gonna just make it from scratch and that
kind of attitude that MIT has people who
actually still make things you know is
is pretty rare you know we don't just
talk about things we don't just
philosophize about things we make things
we make things we test things and
everything we make hopefully impacts the
world from the artists side to the
engineers that you know invented devices
that help people MIT learn to be
fearless yeah ya know so now I want to
flip it around and ask the other side of
the question I think it's actually
harder to answer which is how you've
been here a decade how have you
influenced MIT hmm I don't know if one
person liking you can influence MIT I
mean I think that over the decade I have
seen change in
apartment and the Department of
Architecture there is more openness to
interdisciplinary collaborations more
openness to projects that typically
would be seen on the very periphery of
architectural design because it's
dealing with either urban issues or
landscape issues or interactive design
issues or mobility issues but I think
and I don't know if I'm responsible for
that or just over the last decade all
the departments have become more
interdisciplinary because the problems
now that exist in the world are such
that no one discipline can solve them
it requires the collaboration of a
planner and a you know environmental
scientist and a climatologist you know
or a geologist and a electrical engineer
and a artist maybe so as a head of the
undergraduate program here
how does does that influence where you
feel architecture education should go
and how you're planning the program for
the for the next five ten fifteen yeah I
mean I I think that the undergrads are
the best asset here at MIT they're
incredibly bright and energetic and
unencumbered yet by the like rules of
society and the rules of the profession
so they are they're fearless you know
and for me the important thing about an
undergraduate program in architecture
should be that we train students such
that if they want to go on and get a
masters of architecture they have a
great foundation to do so but we don't
create a program that railroads them
into only getting an architecture
graduate degree that
education really focuses on design
thinking in a broader sense so that they
can go on to doing anything from
management problem-solving to you know
industrial design to architecture and
historically we have had something like
30 30 40 percent go on into other fields
you know so it's I think different from
some undergraduate programs where like
90 percent of the students go into that
area for their master's degree so it
makes it a challenging program to to
develop because you want to make sure
the students have enough exposure to the
kinds of course curriculum that would
prepare them for a masters of
architecture but you want to also make
sure that they're understanding
architecture in the broadest sense that
it is constructing the environment
as opposed to like building a kind of
building and I think you know we try
hard to do that by requiring courses in
both you know art culture and technology
and building technology our students
have to take both so that they
understand the that architecture really
does sit between you know art and
science technology it's like right smack
in the middle there and I think the the
best architects have a strong grasp of
both even as you say it's part of a
liberal arts education that you can do
anything from it and it strikes me as
you're talking that as we go along into
the future society gets more
technological more visual and design
thinking the difference in design
thinking and thinking it seems to me
it's getting less and less and design is
very useful if you have design
principles it applies to a great number
of fields is that yeah I mean I think
for me design thinking is it starts with
how to
analyze a problem in a context and break
that down and it requires thinking
strategically and iteratively about
multiple ways of attacking that problem
through the production of something
right so I think that's where we are
designers and architects because our
goal is actually to make something that
is inhabitable or spatially
experienceable that changes the context
tell me a story one of your favorite
stories of your undergrads the project
or success stories stands out to you I
mean we've had some amazing amazing
undergrads oh there's a graduate of our
program named Lisa Smith who was one of
my favorite students and I met her
initially because she was put on I don't
remember what MIT calls it but she had
some disciplinary hearing or something
so my first day of studio she's like
Professor you and I'm sorry I have to
leave 30 minutes early because I have a
disciplinary hearing about something I
did and I was like oh like I know she's
gonna be a troublemaker it turns out she
had created a survey using MIT other
head but the survey was kind of a joke
survey you know so it was kind of very
clever and funny but because it had the
MIT logo on it she got into some
disciplinary problems but she created
this like megaphone project you know
where she got into trouble again because
she as a public art piece on the streets
she was screaming from a megaphone
you know about certain political issues
and you know and to me she represents
the perfect spirit you know of MIT
undergrads who want to change the world
and are using and yes they get into some
trouble but I think the reason they're
getting into that trouble is because
they're really trying to make other
people aware of certain conditions and
finding ways through that awareness to
then make positive change so it was the
megaphone project or final project or
did you work with her on things maybe so
she could do these things or did you
encourage her to get arrested well you
know I I didn't encourage her to get
arrested but I supported her in finding
ways to get her projects done and and
she graduated from here and then she
went to the Art Institute of Chicago
where she got a master's in design
objects and now she's a very successful
designer but she designs polemical
objects hey Annette what's it political
he now you know she has these like she
designs these mats but they're they have
a message to them a political message to
them that isn't like just text but the
perverseness of the thing or a lamp
that's designed so minimally that it's a
line so it it doesn't look like a lamp
it actually just changes your reading of
the space and perspective you know so we
touched on this a little bit I'm looking
forward just architecture schools in
general over the next decade what's the
biggest challenge um I think the biggest
challenge is gonna be in dealing with
environmental issues you know buildings
of course take up the most energy you
know if you look at charts about you
know what consumes the most energy in
the United States it's it's not cars and
it's not trains and it's not planes it's
actually buildings
so I think that's going to be the
biggest concern for the next generation
how to design in such a way that our
buildings are smart and intelligent
reduce energy use while still creating
an amazing environments for us to do
things in creating collaborative
environments because more of those kinds
of spaces will be necessary but on the
other hand I've read that urban centers
and building places like New York in
some ways are the greenest places of all
because because of the density but in
the United States I don't think we'll
ever have a condition where there will
be you know 12 Manhattan's right so I do
think architects need to think about how
to build sustainably at all kinds of
scales like at the suburban scale
because you know the car is part of the
American dream and until we change the
American dream we're gonna have suburbs
so in a suburban context what can we do
to create the map maximum I love energy
efficiency so youth in the graduate
level architecture design studio of
course you've been teaching for the last
decade yes you ask your students to
quote think design through systems where
did you can't hear that I've been give
it to me referring to the challenge
issued by architecture critic Rainer
Boehm uh-huh yep
so can you tell us a little more about
that and how that works in the context
yeah I mean I think I think it's very
important to think through systems
through designing systems as opposed to
designing a one-off
exquisite design object I've heard the
masterpieces dead well it's it's not I
mean I love masterpieces still but the
masterpiece only addresses one percent
of architecture if that maybe 0.1% of
one percent of our
good texture are the masterpieces
especially in the United States but if
you can design a system whether that
system is a way of design or if you can
design through organizing structural
mechanical and programmatic systems in a
way that works
smartly and still produce amazing spaces
I think that's the key as opposed to all
the top architects producing one-offs
you know that is not going to help
change the the environment that 99% of
the world or 99% of the United States
lives in works and you know plays in
what's a successful example it's a most
standout example of a place or a system
that's doing it right anywhere in the
world we look to is it a there's a
there's some great historical examples
like that I would say range from
Hadrian's villa where yeah so I mean I
think we're where space is organized so
that it deals with in terms of the baths
the hot the cold and there's an
organization to that and a integration
between the architecture and the
technology of the time and the program
in a really integrated way that program
we mean that that's the place you go
down yes yes and and to me that is an
integrated system so integrated that you
can't if you you can't take one thing
out without it all just kind of falling
apart so you know maybe a more recent
example would be like the Centre
Pompidou in Paris but there they codify
the system so like on the outside you
see all the colors and that's because
they're showing which
once our plumbing pipes and which ones
are mechanical ducts and you know intake
outflow etc and that's a building that
literally turns inside out in order to
make the public kind of aware of the
systems of a building I think many
architects like Foster's building in in
Hong Kong the Hong Kong Shanghai bank is
a masterful example of how structural
systems work together in an integrated
way
how about MIT is MIT work well as a
system of buildings I think MIT is a
kind of a campus of ad hoc Ness
you know so it's a it's it's not a it's
not a system it's it's the aftermath of
piecemealing and making things work
ad hoc bit by bit and I think as we move
forward you know every time I'm outside
on a street and I see them digging up my
street because I live in downtown Boston
they're digging it up all the asphalt to
run something who knows what it is
FiOS and then like three weeks later
they're digging it up and then
somebody's running maybe a gas line
under there and to me that's what I mean
by it's not thought through like a
system it's always being dug up and
something added in as opposed to
thinking through what it means to have
infrastructure and then urban context
embedded with buildings I think there is
a different way to think about that
problem it seems like we're coming to
grips with change in architecture as
well I was hearing story the other day
about a brand new building that I spent
years and billions of dollars or no it's
an old building that they retrofitted so
that everybody could have an Ethernet
connection uh-huh by the time they
finished yep didn't need them yeah
technology leaps
you know and architecture is slow so you
know there are many buildings like I
think even the Stata Center here at MIT
between when they started designing it
and when it was built with many many
many years and buildings take a long
time they take a long time to design you
know 12 to 18 months and then they take
a long time to build another 18 to 24
months by the time you add that all up
together from the minute you started to
draw your first line - when people are
moving in we've had four years of
technological revolution you know so
architecture will always remain kind of
because it's still built by humans still
physical so it will always be bridging
kind of low and high technologies I
think that's also what makes
architecture really amazing like I think
of a wall as a form of Technology you
know it separates me from whoever else
and the way you design the wall if you
undulate the wall it has different
acoustic properties if you display the
wall it has different you know optical
qualities so I I still think like the
most basic forms of architecture
technology are incredibly manipulatable
you know and so I think the challenge of
an architect now is we still have to
design amazing walls but now we have to
integrate them with infrastructural
systems you know and technologies that
are constantly changing and it used to
be people told me that Oh buildings are
really only built for a lifespan of like
30 years but I think most people say in
buildings much longer the building I
live in in Boston was built in 1890 you
know and so we have to think that our
buildings are not like 30 years we're
gonna just tear them down and build them
again but how can the building adapt to
transformation
that's a kind of I'm always struck by
this year especially at the design
school how buildings as you say are both
the book technology but their ideas yes
in space and time and now this idea
seems to be flexibility to change
adaptability yeah yeah I think there's
some like every architecture project
every good architecture project is based
on an idea it's based on a concept you
know and I think we saw in the 60s and
70s especially in Japan
after the war a lot of research into
thinking about adaptability
it was the metabolise movement at the
time but adaptability transformation a
way to reimagine the future of Tokyo big
visions and a lot of great heroic
buildings that research these ideas I
think in the u.s. we had that moment too
in the 60s in the 70s and I think in
Boston there are many great I would call
them masterpieces but maybe some people
in Boston would call them abominations
of buildings that were really based on
an idea and testing those ideas talking
about government Center I'm talking
about the range from Exeter library to
the Government Center to Rudolph's
public service building on Cambridge
Street yep Wow defend Government Center
for me well well you know I think the
diagram is interesting too the first
move to create such a giant public plaza
I'm not saying it was done right or that
it works but there was a clarity about
the idea that there would be a huge
public plaza huge right based on Siena I
think quite get the Siena part but and
that the government building would be
kind of transparent to the public the
mayor's office would you know be
where it is with the glass windows that
there'd be a giant courtyard in the
middle that brought daylight internally
that the ground level would have all the
public administration for you know taxes
and whatever for people to go pay their
bills or whatever they do and down on
that lower level so it was meant to be
an incredibly porous building it didn't
work that way because I think after it
was built they closed off most of the
entries and so it turned a circulation
that was about to was supposed to be
about porosity for the public into kind
of a labyrinth you know because of
security issues and the world changed
between the optimism you know of that
publicness to the realities of security
today
I think it's been most successful for me
when they have put up those big screens
when the Red Sox I mean I think you
can't in the United States you can't
have public space without programming
without something happening in that
space because we don't and especially in
Boston we don't necessarily have the
culture or the climate to support the
public just hanging out you know in a
plaza like like Boston City Hall's so
there's a lot of what keeps coming up in
your work really is civic engagement
it's really architecture is it using art
and architecture to promote civic
engagement is that how has that mission
evolved in your field and and where is
it going we're going to see more and
more well I mean I think in I mean I
think there are all kinds of
architectures but I think architecture
is most present in a public context you
know so it used to be that you know like
the forum you know like that
architecture made Civic space
it helped define civic space it helped
foster civic space you know for me I'm
very interested now because we have less
a notion of civic space in the United
States then maybe a more neutral world
word like public space but I'm very
interested in how architecture and
public space work together how public
architectures can help change the
mission of a Institute we just finished
the new headquarters for the Boston
society of Architects in our practice
and the BSA moved from Broad Street to
Atlantic Wharf and with that move they
are leasing a space which is about
15,000 square feet with which has almost
all of that on the second floor and the
ground floor is about a thousand square
feet but it's got window front but it's
on the second floor so that project for
us was all about how can we make a
second floor space because it's a
gallery seem as public as possible and
it's a chapter 91 space so it needs to
be public and it needs to be accessible
300 I don't actually know if you get
money from the state you have to have
have it accessible to the public yes and
it has to be programmed this public
space so it is a architecture gallery
and our idea was that we would create a
move that would try to make that second
floor space seem part of the street it
was very challenging so what we did was
we gave up all the perimeter of that
space to the public programming to the
galleries we pushed all the staff
offices and conference rooms back off
the glass so that you could from the
ground force look up and we created this
green soffit and the ceiling so that's
feeling acted kind of as a facade
because you could see it from the street
and then that sealing like scoop down to
make a grand stair that people kind of
walk up and it painted bright green so
you can't miss it and the idea is you
scoop up the public they end up on the
second floor space and they see the
architecture exhibits in the context of
the city so they can look right out the
window and see like what design is doing
is trying to make an impact and change
in the physical world we inhabit you're
both working architect and working
artist and teachers your students get
involved in your yeah we do take summer
interns and we hire many graduates from
the department and then another way
students get involved is through your up
projects so some of the design research
work I do I hire undergraduates to
please undergraduate research
opportunity it's a really special
program MIT has where MIT the Institute
supports faculty to hire undergraduate
research students for their projects so
I think typically faculty would tend to
hire graduate students over
undergraduate students simply because
they have more experience or you know
they're directly involved in their labs
already but mi t--'s program is really
trying to encourage undergrads and
faculty to have a closer relationship I
think of undergrads an experience they
wouldn't have otherwise so MIT actually
pays the undergrads directly to work on
faculty research projects so one project
that I used Europe students on was a
project called unsolicited small
projects for the Big Dig and it was a
book project where we did a lot of
research on the Big Dig and the kind of
infrastructural overhaul of that project
and then we made speculative conjectures
on a series of projects that are very
very hypothetical that could have
happened or may one day happen you know
to make the Greenway more a vital public
space because even though it is a public
space and it is a park and it is
increasingly well used there was not
much intention or maybe it touches not
the right word but there was not much
specificity in thinking about what could
happen on those parcels those new parks
now that we had this huge way of
connecting the city back together you
know it's unprecedented as an urban
project in the United States and very
little I think was thought about what
you could do beyond just making it a
really nice Park you know so it's an
example well like last year a young
architecture firm called studio Luce
produced a giant hammock one of the
parcels a hammock that like 20 people
could hang on out on simultaneously
some new interventions you know like the
carousel
I think it's been successful but I think
more I'm thinking more like you know why
isn't there like like a parcel that's
just a hundred dirigible you know like
you know like it is such a unique kind
of urban space and I don't think that
the activities on it are particularly
wonderful or unique or you know it's
still kind of it's public but it doesn't
gather people let's say together other
than that water fountain which is super
successful so we need a crystal to come
in I think absolutely I think once a
year they should
have an artist do something that ties
all the parcels along the line together
and then other times there could be
different environmental transformations
I think the Harbor Island pavilion has
been a great success so I think over the
years after it opened there have been
more experiments on how to make the
Greenway Civic space as well as the park
space how have any reaction for even
from your unsolicited oh I think people
were very nervous about it because some
of the proposals were really crazy
because I am frustrated that there are
still so many lanes of traffic and and
like even though it's supposed to be a
linear park because you have to cross a
road every time if you're trying to jog
it's not a really linear experience so I
proposed in one of the projects a
joggers EZ Pass so you would put a
little easy pass on your ankle and you
would jog and as you jogged it would
literally like stop all the lights so
that it privileged the pedestrian as
opposed to our current environment which
always privileges the car so as the
pedestrian jogs not only do all the you
know walk don't walk sights signs work
in their favor but a landscape of trees
follows you so you never have to see the
cars so they run with you
these trees didn't figure it was just
very speculative but you know but that
that book led to actually surprisingly
an invitation for me to join a working
group that is now thinking about public
art on the Greenway public art and
programming on the Greenway so I think
it led to the right thing I've done a
few of these interviews now and it seems
there is a common theme at MIT of
striking out a huge vision never mind
whether it can actually be done or not
but but you know put it put a flag out
there this is where we want to go and
then and then figure the reality
together and you might not get what
you're going but you'll get somewhere
yeah
I think that's right I think that some
idea somehow MIT encourages the big big
ideas the big visions but you know we're
not we're not clowns or professors doing
real research and so you know it's an
interesting way of speculating on a big
vision and what are possible instruments
that lead to that big vision sometimes
it's a kind of almost like a marketing
campaign it's like putting the idea out
there in order to generate enough
activity and discussion and through that
you might create policy change etc in
other cases it's like speculate on that
big vision but what are the intermediary
steps to get to that big vision and I
think that's the luxury of being a
professor at MIT I think in in practice
I'm always thinking of our projects you
know last anywhere from three months to
three years we don't really have
projects that last 30 years in our
practice and you're always under tight
deadlines and you have to work with
realities and you're doing absolutely
the best you know under really tight
time constraints the amazing thing about
the academic environment of MIT is they
really encourage long term thinking and
short term projects that get to that
long term thinking so you can say I had
this idea I don't think we're there to
be able to implement this in the next
even five to ten years but maybe twenty
years out thirty years out you know and
we need to start thinking about this and
talking about this now to get there
that's the luxury and that's why I can't
leave academia even though I also love
practice yeah how do you work out that
balance between your you're everywhere
all the time yeah it is an impossible I
think there is no such thing as balance
yeah how do your students respond to
my key students in particular to this
laying out of the big idea or they are
they thrown by that that they love it I
think it depends I think like for the
graduate students I think they love it I
think the undergraduate students are
actually more skeptical you know like no
you need to teach me like how to really
build real buildings so I think we we
have both I mean I think that's what
makes MIT so unique you introduce them
to the joy of imagination free thinking
letting go of the practical for a moment
I mean you know throughout either
abstract exercises like so abstract that
they don't really know they're designing
they think they're you know one of my
favorite exercises is I asked them to
make a drawing but in order for them to
make a drawing they cannot draw on that
drawing what they have to do is design a
set of rules such that their classmates
each by contributing one hour of their
labor on that piece of paper can produce
the drawing so and then the rules can't
be too elaborate so I make them stick to
one page of rules and it produces the
most extraordinary drawings and this is
what I mean by like thinking through
systems or designing a system I want the
students to design the system for the
drawing they can invent the tool I let
them invent the tool if they want and
then a set of rules and then you know
you know one student you know says you
know draw this specific pattern until
you hit the edge and then go this you
know like so it creates a chain pattern
another student you know asked them to
put the paper on a wall and like with
their hand try to find you know because
our walls are full of holes because of
all the pushpins for printing up and
like copy every location of every hole
and then the next student to like
connect all the dots
and it produces beautiful drawings
because they're not so willful about
some metaphoric poetic
intent but they are precise and they are
based on a logic you know that the
student constructs and what they learn
from that project I hope is that design
is not about pure individual authorship
anymore design requires the
participation of many but you as the
designer need to make sure that there is
clarity about how that design will be
executed that's one lesson from that
exercise and I think students every time
are just profoundly impressed by how
beautiful the drawings are like from
just an aesthetic point of view the
drawings always end up much more
beautiful than they could have done if
they sat with a blank piece of paper and
try to draw something that's great where
do you go from there what's your next
yeah well I also do exercise where
sometimes I ask students to take like a
historic building like a 60s and 70s
building and through a you know we get
we blow up the photographs really large
and I ask them to just sort of Photoshop
like reimagine it you know so it's not
again working from a blank piece of
paper but you know how how would you
have done it differently you know so one
thing they learn is they have to figure
out why the architect the original
architect made those decisions then they
come to really appreciate this decision
sometimes they're like I can't do
anything it's really good just leave it
but I say okay
it was designed as a library now you
have to reimagine it as an energy farm
you know and then they kind of loosen up
and they go wild and they have
fun so is there something in this
recontextualization or D familiarising
that is involved with your artwork like
white noise white light or the
Philadelphia yeah I mean I think you did
you people yeah no I think there is
something I think that's really
important in design education that you
need to for students break down what
they think architecture is many students
when they come into an architecture
program they say oh I've been around
buildings all my life I know exactly
what a building is teach me how to draw
plans and go on my merry way and design
buildings and the first thing is like
well what what is the building you know
what are the things that create or not
create social interaction you know how
do you deal with the ground plane how
does something meet the ground plane how
do you think about barriers you know
from the labyrinth to the continuity how
can you rethink circulation you know and
so we try to abstract them those
exercises so students really understand
space and not buildings because our goal
is to design space and that produces
buildings you know a building is just a
volume that separates you from your
larger environment right so what is an
envelope
how can envelopes perform you know from
an energy point of view but also from a
social point of view like certain
buildings like we were saying City Hall
it was meant to be porous but it
absolutely doesn't work like how can you
design a porous building so we're
talking about architecture moving
forward as may be always as a design of
space rather than a design of buildings
so let's speculate a little about the
future if you had a magic wand and could
redesign the campus take the Photoshop
your real world is nothing open it up
and make it more of a designed
functioning way to do well I think the
first I do many things about
one of the first schemes I think I would
do just from having been here so long
and understanding of the way people
think and work and we make a terrible
campus and it would be vetoed by all
architects and planners but I think the
MIT community would love to be in one
building so it would be 1 mega building
that would clear across the whole campus
there'd be lots of perforations in it
for courtyards so there'd be lots of day
lighting etc but it would allow you to
get from any department to any
department without going outside and it
would have lots of I don't know what you
would call it
non non defined spaces in terms of who
owns it so that you could have impromptu
research generated by multiple groups
simultaneously it would be incredibly
transparent you know it'd be all glass
on the interior so that you could see
what was going on and that would be no
more than two floors maybe three floors
max which is not a great use of the land
but what it means is everyone would walk
so no one would need to take an elevator
and go into a dark cube one of the
stories I heard once is from a friend of
mine who used to work at Bell Labs and
he said it was an amazing place to work
and that so much impromptu discussions
and innovations really occurred through
serendipity because people would run
into each other on the stairs because
everyone used the stairs and Bell Labs
and all the great kind of discussions
happened on the landings I thought that
was fantastic so if I could redesign MIT
would be one giant mega building a lot
of transparency and daylighting with a
bunt millions of courtyards but
everything would be 2 or 3 floors so
that everyone would run into each other
on landings and it would be designed in
such a way that no one would take one
route maybe it would be designed so that
always the routes changed or you
couldn't always take the same
because I think you get into a habit at
MIT you go down this corridor this
corridor this corner this court you read
into the same people you know but if the
routes were always changing and this
labyrinth of the future MIT you run into
all kinds of people pass all kinds of
things and be like huh well someone is
you know creating a robot that climbs
that wall the Gecko that's kind of
interesting because I'm researching a 3m
product that is about sticky surfaces
maybe I should collaborate with him or
talk to him it's very cool I was at
Pixar once years and years ago shortly
after they began and I don't know what
they were like now but at that time they
were in giant Quonset huts kind of
airplane hangar buildings it was the
same deal and people roll around on
scooters take it and leave it scooter
yeah it's a little bit like that no I
mean MIT has that it's embryonic and not
fully realized but it does seem to me
that there's a lot of meeting in the
hallways infinite corridor yeah yeah but
I feel like it is like the spaces are
not the kind of spaces you want to just
linger in forever and ever you know it
is just the result of corridors and
hallways and bridges and connections as
opposed to being really thought of as a
network spring comes back to the fast
festival where the pictures I saw it was
not here but the green building in that
area it did seem to make it into a
networked community a public space in a
way that to me at least it just it feels
a little bit yes yeah yeah was that a
deliberate aim well you know um yeah I
mean I think that like for me for the
windscreen installation I did on the
green building for me like that place on
the campus is is strange you know
because first it's a tower but also
because it's so windy nobody enjoys
being in that space and even though the
other side of the Green Building runs
parallel to the extension of the
infinite corridor because the weather is
always so bad nobody uses it so I do
think the goal was to actually take
spaces that are underutilized on mi
t--'s campus and then make them more
utilized or to use some aspects of them
- so what are you working on now project
oh we're doing a couple interesting
projects so we were asked recently to do
a permanent installation art piece as
part of the general service
administration's percent for art and
architecture program so it's fun because
I get to change hats and be the artist
in an architecture project but this is
for this San Ysidro border crossing
which is the largest land border
crossing in the world and so they're
expanding it there will be thirty four
lanes of traffic they process 3,000
people an hour in the pedestrian lane
for you Mexico yes yes 3,000 people know
it doesn't seem right does it must meet
three thousand three thousand people a
day doesn't sound right either
yeah and and we're doing a solar-powered
canopy in the City of Phoenix on
Roosevelt row that's another project on
the architectural front we're looking at
redeveloping Avery and Hayward Street
here in Boston the streetscape what else
are we doing we have a lot of projects
oh we're doing the plaza in front of
Harvard Science Center we're working
with stas which is the landscape firm to
rethink that and we're specifically
focusing on the media aspects lighting
and media
Beks of that project so people say you
should never go into business with your
friends you're in business with your
husband how does that work out we're
still friends um so you know my husband
was one year ahead of me in undergrad at
Cornell so he was an upperclassman by
one year and when we graduated he went
to New York and then I went to Boston
like for my masters and our Cambridge
for my master's and he continued on his
track so he you know worked for eight
years at kpf big firm in New York and
then three years for Diller Scofidio
which is the boutique firm that did the
ICA project here in Boston and I did my
thing I did my you know public space
installations I did small-scale
residential projects and in I remember
2006 I said we joined forces
we're like white going to practice are
we gonna have because he has big you
know he did towers at kpf he worked on
the tallest buildings in the world and
Diller Scofidio he worked on really
important cultural venues like the
Institute of Contemporary Art and
Lincoln Center and me I had done you
know an installation of the Guggenheim
and you know for the Athens Olympics and
much smaller scale interventions a dress
what kind of firm are we gonna have
so we've combined our forces and it's
been an adventure I mean I think we I
think we both really rely on each
other's opinion we really respect it but
we have very different approaches to
design so it works out well the way
they've kind of embodying this future
for the field that you're talking about
combining designing space and art
influences with the work
more traditional building approach yep
yeah so you represent the future hahaha
don't come back at another 20 years in
good hopefully we'll still be in
operation yeah so why do you teach yeah
I asked I don't know I can't not teach I
mean I feel I feel always inspired by
teaching I feel like if if like I'm on
sabbatical this semester so I've been
really focusing on the work in the
studio in the office and I miss teaching
like I I have this itch to be around
young energetic people who are
unencumbered by the realities of the
world you know and they encourage me to
always think you know with with open
eyes with open mind about a problem and
because I'm professing a certain way I
think that design should be thought
about as I profess to them you know I
can't be a hypocrite so it keeps our
office I think and studio having the
highest ambitions in terms of design and
not giving in and kind of selling out to
the realities of the world you know they
keep you on your toes you keep me on my
toes yeah that's great
I think that's all I have thank you so
much thank you thank you so much